As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal.
作为7-Eleven的脆皮鸡三明治，人们总说我声音很大。我心想，是啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你指望我耳语吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反思一下吧。我是说，我知道我很难搞。我大胆，我多汁。给我撒点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一顿完整的大餐。
And with seven rewards, I'm just $4. Quiet. No. Krispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 362326, participating stores only well supplies lastly out for full terms. Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association.
有了7-Eleven的奖励，我只要4美元。安静？不。脆皮、多汁、只要4美元？非常可以。仅在7-Eleven有售。价值362326，仅限参与门店，售完即止，详情请见完整条款。您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。
The crisis at the U.S. southern border shows no signs of stopping and the American system designed to serve immigrants and refugees is overwhelmed and ill-prepared to handle the hundreds of thousands of people who have been apprehended since October 2018. Many immigrants are fleeing their home countries to escape violence, poverty, and oppression, and are seeking protection in the U.S. Psychologists all around the country have been moved to help with this humanitarian crisis by providing mental health services, forensic psychological evaluations, and advocacy services to these vulnerable people. One such psychologist is Dr. Claudette Antunia, a volunteer forensic psychological evaluator at the Northwest Immigrant Rights Project. She provides pro bono evaluations to this nonprofit agency in the state of Washington that have helped hundreds of immigrants attain asylum or other forms of legal relief available to undocumented immigrants
美国南部边境的危机毫无平息迹象，旨在服务移民和难民的美国系统已不堪重负，且准备不足，无法应对自2018年10月以来被捕的数十万人。许多移民为了逃避暴力、贫困和压迫而逃离祖国，并在美国寻求保护。全国各地的心理学家都深受触动，通过为这些弱势群体提供心理健康服务、法医心理评估和倡导服务，来帮助应对这场人道主义危机。克劳黛特·安图尼亚（Claudette Antunia）博士就是这样一位心理学家，她是西北移民权利项目（Northwest Immigrant Rights Project）的一名志愿法医心理评估员。她为华盛顿州的这家非营利机构提供无偿评估，帮助数百名移民获得了庇护或其他形式的法律救济，这些救济适用于无证移民。
so they can stay in the U.S. She's also involved with a refugee mental health resource network, an APA initiative led by our division on trauma psychology, and she's a member of our immigration working group. Welcome, Dr. Antunia. It's wonderful to have you here to talk about this very important topic. Thank you very much for asking me. I imagine most of our listeners haven't met or been in close contact with a person who's made this long and treacherous journey from their home country to the U.S. border, to then be apprehended by immigration officials, possibly separated from their children or other family members. To bring the images we've seen in the news to life for our listeners, can you describe the mental and physical conditions of the people you work with?
这样他们就能留在美国。她还参与了难民心理健康资源网络，这是由我们创伤心理学分会领导的一项美国心理学会（APA）倡议，她也是我们移民工作组的成员。欢迎您，安图尼亚博士。很高兴您能来这里讨论这个非常重要的话题。非常感谢您的邀请。我想我们的大多数听众还没有见过或近距离接触过那些从祖国长途跋涉、历经艰险来到美国边境，随后被移民官员逮捕，甚至可能与子女或其他家庭成员分离的人。为了让听众们能直观地感受到我们在新闻中看到的画面，您能描述一下您所接触的人的心理和生理状况吗？
Most of the people that I work with have gone through an arduous journey to get here. By the time they actually cross the border, they're exhausted. They've been through deserts, they've been through swamps, they've been through water, rain, a vegetation that's outgrown them, and many different forms of transportation. Many times they walk, many times they get a bus. Sometimes they get on the train where they have seen other people get injured because the train goes very fast and people going on the roof of the train and falling off. So they have seen all kinds of situations.
我接触的大多数人都经历了一段艰苦的旅程才来到这里。当他们真正越过边境时，他们已经精疲力竭了。他们穿过沙漠、沼泽、水域、雨林，穿过比人还高的植被，并使用了多种交通工具。很多时候他们步行，很多时候他们坐公共汽车。有时他们会坐火车，在那里他们目睹了其他人受伤，因为火车开得很快，人们爬上车顶却掉了下来。所以他们见过各种各样的状况。
And they've been used and mistreated by some and then occasionally helped by others. All of a sudden, a grateful hand will be extended by someone who offers them some food and some water. And many times now they're coming with their small children. So this arduous journey for an adult is hard. Bringing children with them is excruciatingly difficult. So by the time they get here, they're exhausted mentally and physically. Close to you in Tacoma, Washington is a large immigration and customs enforcement detention center in Tacoma, Washington. Can you describe what it's like there?
他们被一些人利用和虐待，但也偶尔得到其他人的帮助。突然间，一个感恩的手伸向他们，提供一些食物和水。现在，他们中很多人带着年幼的孩子。所以，对于成年人来说，这段艰苦的旅程已经很艰难了。带着孩子一起走更是极其困难。因此，当他们到达这里时，他们在心理和生理上都已经筋疲力尽了。在您华盛顿州塔科马市附近，有一个大型的移民和海关执法局拘留中心。您能描述一下那里是什么样的吗？
It's a huge warehouse in the port of Seattle that looks like any other warehouse. It's kind of hidden among all different kinds of warehouses they have. They have no programs for people. They have a library which is obsolete. and they have pods where adult men and women are housed. That's all they are. They're just actually housed. They have a small little patio where they can occasionally go out to play some, shoot some baskets.
那是一个位于西雅图港的巨大仓库，看起来和其他仓库没什么两样。它隐藏在各种各样的仓库之中。他们没有为人们提供任何项目。他们有一个已经过时的图书馆，还有关押成年男女的隔间。仅此而已。他们实际上只是被关在那里。他们有一个小小的露台，偶尔可以出去玩玩，投投篮。
But that is about all. They're not, it's fenced in the entire perimeter. And they're constantly watched by the officers that are in charge of taking care of them. But they actually have no relief, but boredom is one of the most difficult things that they have to deal with. Some of them choose to work for a dollar a day, either cleaning toilets, cleaning floors, and some of them are fortunate enough to work in the kitchen. I think that is the plus people try to get to work in the kitchen because they can get some additional food. Other than that, they're just housed. So it's 1,500 people or more plus could be there at any time.
但也就仅此而已。整个周边都被围起来了。他们时刻受到负责看管他们的官员的监视。但他们实际上没有任何解脱，无聊是他们必须面对的最困难的事情之一。他们中的一些人选择每天工作一美元，要么打扫厕所，要么打扫地板，有些人幸运的话可以在厨房工作。我认为这是人们努力争取去厨房工作的好处，因为他们可以得到一些额外的食物。除此之外，他们只是被关着。所以任何时候那里都可能有1500人甚至更多。
So we're the third largest detention center in the United States. Can you explain what a forensic evaluator does? So the forensic evaluator is usually contacted by an immigration attorney to respond to the type of legal relief that is being offered and whether or not that individual fits into that category. So it is a neutral document, an objective document of how that person fits. and responds to the questions that are being asked in terms of their eligibility and criteria for any of the legal forms of relief that are available. So it's a psychosocial evaluation, trauma-informed, objective, and neutral document. It is not an advocacy.
所以我们是美国第三大拘留中心。您能解释一下法医评估员是做什么的吗？法医评估员通常由移民律师联系，以回应所提供的法律救济类型，以及该个人是否符合该类别。因此，这是一份中立的、客观的文件，说明该人如何符合条件，并回答有关其是否有资格获得任何可用法律救济形式的问题。所以这是一份心理社会评估，是一份创伤知情、客观且中立的文件。这不是倡导。
We're not trying to point out why they should stay here. We're just saying this person fits the criteria and this is why. So it is our job to make sure that we can respond to the question. What services do you provide as part of the refugee mental health resource network? Okay. So the original reason for having the refugee network is because the scarcity of resources for individuals who know how to do the psychological evaluation that accompanies the application for legal relief. So because it was the attorneys, usually immigration attorneys were seeking individuals, it was a response to being able to provide individuals who do this kind of work,
我们不是试图指出他们为什么应该留在这里。我们只是说这个人符合标准，这就是原因。所以我们的工作是确保我们能够回答这个问题。作为难民心理健康资源网络的一部分，您提供什么服务？好的。建立难民网络的最初原因是，对于那些知道如何进行心理评估以配合法律救济申请的人来说，资源非常匮乏。因为通常是移民律师在寻找相关人员，这是为了能够提供从事此类工作的人员，
who can either provide it for a fee or for no fee, depending on the community and what's being asked. And the other thing is that the refugee network now also has webinars where we try to talk about the different ways in which we do the evaluation, but also the different consultation with one another mentoring service. So it's an attempt to address the issue of scarce resources to provide something that we definitely need to be able to do. You touched on something called trauma-informed care. So can you talk a little bit more about that? And it's importance in working with immigrants and refugees? Well, for the most part, individuals who have taken a long journey who first made
他们可以根据社区和要求，选择收费或免费提供服务。另一件事是，难民网络现在也有网络研讨会，我们尝试讨论我们进行评估的不同方式，以及彼此之间的咨询和指导服务。所以这是为了解决资源匮乏的问题，提供我们绝对需要做的事情。您提到了“创伤知情护理”。您能多谈谈这一点吗？以及它在与移民和难民合作中的重要性？嗯，在很大程度上，那些长途跋涉的人，首先在他们自己的国家做出了选择，即他们所面对的一切已不再是
a choice in their own country that whatever they were dealing with was no longer acceptable. sustainable, and they make the decision to come. That's the first piece of trauma that individuals have to deal with. Their roles in life are going to change. They're separating from other extended family members, from perhaps some property that may have, so they're aware of life, their customs, their community. And that's the first part of leaving their country.
可持续的，于是他们做出了离开的决定。这是个人必须面对的第一部分创伤。他们生活中的角色将会改变。他们与大家庭成员分离，可能还要放弃他们可能拥有的财产，所以他们意识到生活、习俗、社区都变了。这是离开祖国的第一部分。
And then they have to make this arduous trip full of obstacles. So an individual who is assessing that level of trauma needs to go back and take a look at what these individuals have lost as a result of what they've experienced in their own countries, the trajectory of getting here, and what life and assimilation will be like in this country. So the trauma that people have sustained is expressed in many different ways depending on your culture. So you, some individuals who do not have access to an attorney might have to face a judge who doesn't speak their language and may not be able to express and tell their story. So we need to be able to address that issue. We're kind of, we're telling the story of this individual and why they're here. Can you talk about how important it is to build trust with these vulnerable populations? I imagine today's political climate may make people afraid.
然后他们必须完成这段充满障碍的艰苦旅程。因此，评估这种创伤水平的人需要回过头来看看，这些人因为在自己国家所经历的事情、到达这里的轨迹，以及在这个国家的生活和同化将会是什么样子，而失去了什么。所以人们所遭受的创伤会根据文化的不同以许多不同的方式表现出来。所以，一些无法接触到律师的人可能不得不面对一个不懂他们语言的法官，可能无法表达和讲述他们的故事。所以我们需要能够解决这个问题。我们是在讲述这个人的故事以及他们为什么在这里。您能谈谈与这些弱势群体建立信任有多重要吗？我想今天的政治气候可能会让人们害怕。
to trust the various systems that are designed to help them. The willingness to listen to their story is extremely important and to not think of it as something that's time consumed and you need to have it out with and just talk to somebody for half an hour and see what you can get. You have to really be able to listen to the story that they're willing to tell
去信任那些旨在帮助他们的各种系统。倾听他们故事的意愿极其重要，不要认为这只是浪费时间，你只需要花半小时和某人谈谈，看看能得到什么。你必须真正能够倾听他们愿意讲述的故事，
and recognize when they're not able to articulate what has truly happened to them. I mean, we have 12. 14, 16-year-old girls who are told before they leave that they need to take precautions to not get pregnant because they'll probably be raped. So they're given pills and sent off on the trip and hoping that nothing will happen to them. So there's a lot that goes into being able to pull out that story. about what it was like to make that decision to come and to then face the trip and recognize what they have gone through. So we need to be able to listen to the story and be able to tell the judge, what we call the trier of fact,
并识别出他们何时无法清晰表达真正发生在他们身上的事情。我的意思是，我们有12、14、16岁的女孩，她们在离开前被告知需要采取预防措施以免怀孕，因为她们很可能会被强奸。所以她们被给了药，然后踏上旅程，希望什么都不会发生。所以，能够挖掘出关于做出离开决定、面对旅程并认识到他们经历了什么的故事，需要付出很多努力。所以我们需要能够倾听这个故事，并能够告诉法官，也就是我们所说的“事实认定者”，
so that they can make a decision as to whether or not someone is eligible to stay in this country or not. Can you explain what cultural competency is and how critical it is in this type of work? It's more than just being able to speak the language. It's being able to understand what they have dealt with in terms of their own community, where they come from, the kinds of objectives and values that they have. And we need to set aside what we know about ourselves and be able to take a look at somebody else's story and understand it from their perspective and not try to. impose a particular bias that we might have towards that culture or towards their practices or to their way of life. So really being able to put that aside, understanding that we have our own biases, making
这样他们才能决定某人是否有资格留在这个国家。您能解释一下什么是文化胜任力，以及它在这种工作中有多关键吗？这不仅仅是能够说这种语言。这是能够理解他们在自己的社区、他们来自哪里、他们所拥有的目标和价值观方面所面对的一切。我们需要放下我们对自己所知的一切，能够审视别人的故事，从他们的角度去理解它，而不是试图强加我们可能对那种文化、他们的习俗或他们的生活方式所持有的某种偏见。所以，真正能够放下这些，理解我们有自己的偏见，确保
sure that we understand what they are so that we can look at individuals from their perspective when they're telling us their story and not making assumptions about what has happened to them. So cultural competence is, and it's cultural competence. cultural empathy, it's really being able to put yourself in somebody else's shoes. And it seems stricent. It seems like we should be able to do that. It's actually not that, not that easy because we, we are so full of biases and ways of seeing the world in our own way that we, it's difficult for us sometimes to be able to understand somebody else's and where they're coming from.
我们了解这些偏见是什么，这样当他们向我们讲述他们的故事时，我们才能从他们的角度看待个人，而不是对发生在他们身上的事情做出假设。所以文化胜任力，就是文化胜任力、文化同理心，它确实是能够设身处地为他人着想。这看起来很严格。看起来我们应该能够做到这一点。实际上并非如此，并不那么容易，因为我们充满了偏见和以自己的方式看待世界的方法，以至于我们有时很难理解别人的想法和他们的出发点。
And particularly when they don't speak the language. So I can give you a, an example of one, and I wrote a little piece about the cultural competence is extremely important in just making recommendations about as individuals' life and to understand that there may be three different kinds of an indigenous language, and when we get an interpreter for one particular type of indigenous language, we may not be really addressing all of their concerns. So that is is another skill that one has to develop to make sure that you when you have to use interpreters, as we often have to. I mean, I speak English and Spanish, but I don't speak 220 different native indigenous languages from South America. And to be able to grasp that piece that they're
特别是当他们不说这种语言时。我可以给你举个例子，我写了一篇关于文化胜任力在对个人生活提出建议时极其重要的小文章，要理解可能存在三种不同的土著语言，当我们为某种特定的土著语言找到翻译时，我们可能并没有真正解决他们所有的担忧。所以这是一个人必须发展的另一项技能，以确保当你必须使用翻译时，就像我们经常必须做的那样。我的意思是，我会说英语和西班牙语，但我不会说南美洲220种不同的土著语言。为了能够抓住他们试图告诉我们的那部分信息，
trying to tell us and to listen really carefully to what they're not saying so that we can really be able to tell their story. You were interviewed by our magazine for members called monitor on psychology in fall of 2018. And in the story, you described how you helped three women who were forcibly separated from their children. Can you explain what happened to them and what the outcome was? You know, I don't always know what the outcome is. On those particular cases, I do.
并非常仔细地倾听他们没有说出来的内容，这样我们才能真正讲述他们的故事。2018年秋季，我们的会员杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）采访了您。在报道中，您描述了您是如何帮助三名被迫与子女分离的妇女的。您能解释一下发生了什么以及结果如何吗？你知道，我并不总是知道结果如何。在那些特定的案例中，我知道。
But as a forensic psychologist, we're really supposed to stay very neutral. And we may never know what the outcome is of a particular evaluation, unless the attorney wishes to share that with us. but that first wave of parents and mothers being separated, there were several hundred mothers who were sent to a, to what we call a C-TAC detention facility, but it's actually a, it's very different than a detention facility for immigrants and immigration facility. And they were in state of shock.
但作为一名法医心理学家，我们真的应该保持非常中立。除非律师希望与我们分享，否则我们可能永远不知道特定评估的结果。但第一波父母和母亲被分离时，有几百名母亲被送往我们所谓的C-TAC拘留设施，但这实际上与移民拘留设施非常不同。她们处于休克状态。
They could not believe they had never heard of children being separated. young children being separated from them, and they did not expect that to happen. And all their attempts to try and find out what had happened to their children were dismissed as if they shouldn't care. They should just only care about themselves and not care about where their kids are. As a mother and a grandmother there is, that would be very difficult for me to put aside just my own interest and not know what happened to my children. So these women were expressing tremendous amount of pain.
她们无法相信，她们从未听说过孩子会被分离。年幼的孩子被与她们分离，她们没想到会发生这种情况。她们试图找出孩子发生了什么的所有努力都被驳回了，就好像她们不应该关心一样。她们应该只关心自己，而不应该关心孩子在哪里。作为一名母亲和祖母，对我来说，要放下我自己的利益，不知道我的孩子发生了什么，那将是非常困难的。所以这些妇女表达了巨大的痛苦。
They were in shock. They were constantly anxious trying to figure out how to connect with someone who could give them some information. Eventually, they were able to be heard in a court. They had a hearing. And so they were able to be eventually reunited with their children. But it took months. And in the meantime, they were. time, they only had each other to console. There was no one else who really cared about what they
她们处于休克状态，不断地焦虑，试图弄清楚如何联系到能给她们提供信息的人。最终，她们得以在法庭上被听到。她们举行了听证会。所以她们最终得以与孩子们团聚。但这花了几个月的时间。在此期间，她们只有彼此可以安慰。没有其他人真正关心她们正在经历什么。
were going through. So they supported one another through this very difficult process. APA has come out quite strongly against the policy of separating families of the border, citing the psychological harm that comes from it, including toxic stress, post-traumatic stress disorder, sleep disturbances, substance abuse, social withdrawal. Can you describe what you've with your work? I would say I've seen most of what Sanda Diaz have five. People express their what they have gone through in many different ways. Some people just shut down. Other people are one day are okay and the next day they're not. So is this really who they always portray or is this is just situational, so we need to kind of understand what that is like.
所以她们在这个非常困难的过程中互相支持。美国心理学会（APA）强烈反对在边境分离家庭的政策，指出由此产生的心理伤害，包括毒性压力、创伤后应激障碍、睡眠障碍、药物滥用、社交退缩。您能描述一下您在工作中看到的吗？我想说我看到了桑达·迪亚兹（Sanda Diaz）提到的五种情况中的大部分。人们以许多不同的方式表达他们所经历的事情。有些人只是封闭自己。有些人一天还好，第二天就不行了。所以这真的是他们一直表现出来的样子，还是仅仅是情境性的，所以我们需要理解那是什么样的。
So we see people with all different types of anxiety, adjustment disorders, PTSD, of course, but some of them are depressed and some of them may not be as depressed. Some of them spend hours just being paranoid about what is going to happen to them if they're being forced to go to return to their country, what that would be like. So there's a gamut of emotional expression and psychological injury that occurs to both adults, adolescents, and children. And that is what the, you know, if you could say the educational piece of immigration psychology is just looking at the variety of responses that people have to what they've gone through.
所以我们看到人们有各种各样的焦虑、适应障碍、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），当然，但有些人很抑郁，有些人可能没那么抑郁。有些人花几个小时只是对如果他们被迫返回自己的国家会发生什么感到偏执，那会是什么样子。所以，成年人、青少年和儿童都会出现各种各样的情绪表达和心理伤害。这就是，如果你愿意说的话，移民心理学的教育部分，就是观察人们对他们所经历的事情的各种反应。
And the detention centers of the border have been described as dirty, crowded, lacking, adequate food and communicable diseases are spread easily. What is the psychological impact of being held in those conditions, especially for children? And are those conditions what you see at the CTAC location you mentioned? No, the CTAC location is actually for adults as well. We do not have in the state of Washington. We do not have a child where children have been detained. We have a facility where adolescents are being held that are usually unaccompanied.
边境的拘留中心被描述为肮脏、拥挤、缺乏足够的食物，传染病很容易传播。在这些条件下被关押的心理影响是什么，特别是对儿童而言？这些条件和你提到的CTAC地点看到的一样吗？不，CTAC地点实际上也是针对成年人的。在华盛顿州，我们没有关押儿童的地方。我们有一个关押青少年的设施，他们通常是无人陪伴的。
And I have seen many of those children. Many of those young folks have not had a good educational foundation. And so when they try to test their intellectual development, there's a lot of concern about what kind of educational exposure we can place these young people at. So I'm already seeing them when they have been detained in a facility, a group phone facility for some time. and I don't see the young children, but I am aware because I have colleagues who have contacted me and seeking resources about how to go about evaluating children who are non-responsive, some who can't stop crying, some who are screaming and hollering for their parents. So each situation and each child responds to their situation very differently,
我见过很多那样的孩子。许多年轻人没有良好的教育基础。所以当他们试图测试他们的智力发展时，人们非常担心我们可以让这些年轻人接触什么样的教育。所以我看到他们时，他们已经在设施中被拘留了一段时间，一个集体设施。我没有看到年幼的孩子，但我知道，因为我有同事联系我，寻求关于如何评估那些没有反应的儿童的资源，有些孩子哭个不停，有些孩子为父母尖叫和哭喊。所以每种情况和每个孩子对他们处境的反应都非常不同，
and we have to be able to understand where they are developmentally and where that fits in to the trajectory of their response to distress, which may be very different from what we would expect children who have grown up in different kinds of environments. So for many people who are released into the country temporarily while they await their time in court, deportation is a constant threat for them and many other immigrants and refugees. people in those situations are dealing with this chronic uncertainty. Can you describe the psychological toll that takes on a person? I see it manifested a lot in extreme anxiety. So, for instance, many individuals who are still waiting for their day in court.
我们必须能够理解他们处于什么样的发展阶段，以及这如何符合他们对痛苦的反应轨迹，这可能与我们对在不同环境中长大的儿童的期望非常不同。对于许多被暂时释放到国内等待法庭审判的人来说，驱逐出境对他们和其他许多移民和难民来说是一个持续的威胁。处于这些情况中的人们正在处理这种长期的不确定性。您能描述一下这对一个人造成的心理伤害吗？我看到它在极度焦虑中表现得很多。例如，许多仍在等待法庭审判的人。
And this is not just a couple of months. This is sometimes years that they're waiting in limbo. And they don't know what is going to happen to them. So they're constantly fearful, you know, if they can go and seek assistance from anybody. They're no longer going to the kinds of activities that they used to go to. Frequently, there's a, there have been several articles about the toxic stress that people are experiencing in that they won't go to a doctor's appointment. They won't take their child to a doctor because they're concerned. that somebody in the office might report them to immigration,
这不仅仅是几个月。有时他们要在不确定中等待几年。他们不知道会发生什么。所以他们一直很害怕，你知道，如果他们能去寻求任何人的帮助。他们不再参加他们过去常参加的活动。经常有几篇关于人们正在经历的毒性压力的文章，他们不会去看医生预约。他们不会带孩子去看医生，因为他们担心办公室里的某个人可能会向移民局举报他们，
even though their child might be a U.S. citizen. They won't seek assistance. They won't go to church. They don't go to soccer games or any kind of activity that they used to enjoy with their children because they have concerns that they may be picked up when their child will be left abandoned. There are in some cities teachers who will pick up the kids because the parents don't want to take the children to school because they're afraid they could be picked up. So teachers have volunteered to pick up these children from different schools, from different homes and bring them to school so the parents don't have to make the arduous trip. So it's changing the way in which they're living their lives.
即使他们的孩子可能是美国公民。他们不会寻求帮助。他们不会去教堂。他们不去参加足球比赛或任何他们过去常和孩子们一起享受的活动，因为他们担心当他们被带走时，他们的孩子会被遗弃。在一些城市，有老师会去接孩子，因为父母不想带孩子去学校，因为他们害怕自己会被带走。所以老师们自愿从不同的学校、不同的家庭接这些孩子，把他们带到学校，这样父母就不必进行那段艰苦的旅程。所以这正在改变他们生活的方式。
It's frightening. It's toxic. It's distressing. They just can't do the same things that they used to do. Our country is deeply divided about what to do about the influx of immigrants coming to the border. As you know, what do you want to say to people who believe that immigrants should be immediately turned away or that families should continue to be separated? I mean, you're obviously sharing these very stories about people who are experiencing a lot of stress
这很可怕。这有毒。这令人痛苦。他们只是不能做他们过去常做的同样的事情。我们的国家在如何处理涌向边境的移民问题上存在严重分歧。如您所知，您想对那些认为应该立即拒绝移民或应该继续分离家庭的人说些什么？我的意思是，您显然在分享这些关于正在经历巨大压力和焦虑以及创伤情况的人们的故事。
and anxiety and traumatic situations. So what do you have to say to those who were on the opposite end of the spectrum? Well, I don't have to say that I'm biased because I am an immigrant. I am from Peru. But my father was invited to this country and went to school at Cornell and returned to Peru where I was born. And then later on decided to come back to the United States at the invitation of the U.S. government. And so it did not understand and appreciate the valued immigrants have to this overall culture. We are a land of immigrants.
那么您对那些处于相反立场的人有什么要说的吗？嗯，我不得不说我有偏见，因为我是一名移民。我来自秘鲁。但我父亲受邀来到这个国家，在康奈尔大学上学，然后回到了我出生的秘鲁。后来又应美国政府的邀请决定回到美国。所以我不理解也不欣赏移民对这种整体文化的价值。我们是一个移民国家。
I strongly believe the sayings that are on the Statue of Liberty. My great-grandparents were from Poland, and they escaped the world. So unless you're Native American, your family is from somewhere. And I think we have contributed to the fabric of the society. And it is something that we need to be very cognizant of. If all of the immigrants, the undocumented immigrants left, we'd have a food shortage. People who work in restaurants, people who work in high tech. I mean, we come from all over the world.
我坚信自由女神像上的名言。我的曾祖父母来自波兰，他们逃离了世界。所以除非你是美洲原住民，否则你的家人来自某个地方。我认为我们为这个社会的结构做出了贡献。这是我们需要非常清楚的事情。如果所有的移民，无证移民都离开了，我们将面临粮食短缺。在餐馆工作的人，在高科技行业工作的人。我的意思是，我们来自世界各地。
And I think we have a value. And I don't see what the struggle is. and continues to be to not allow them to participate and create an even better America than the one we're living in now. What are some incorrect assumptions you think people have about immigrants and refugees to go along with the question I just asked? Yeah. Well, that's an interesting one because there have been several myth destroyers
我认为我们有价值。我不明白为什么还要挣扎，不让他们参与并创造一个比我们现在生活的更好的美国。您认为人们对移民和难民有哪些不正确的假设，以配合我刚才的问题？是的。嗯，那是一个有趣的问题，因为已经有几个神话粉碎者存在了，我是知道的。梅尔瓦·瓦斯奎兹（Melva Vasquez）提出过几个。其中之一是关于不想学习英语的神话。我认为那是不成立的。我们有文献证明，大多数来到这个国家的移民都想学习英语，但他们不想抛弃自己的文化或语言。他们想成为双语，有时是三语。所以他们不想学习语言是一个神话。
that have been around that I'm aware of. Melva Vasquez had come up with a couple of them. And one of them was the myth about not wanting to learn English. I think that that's not founded. We have literature to prove that most immigrants who come to this country want to learn English, but they don't want to leave their culture or their language behind. They want to be bilingual, sometimes trilingual. So that is a myth that they don't want to learn the language.
现在，有些人确实无法掌握两种或三种语言。他们有真正的困难。但这并不意味着他们不想。这只是意味着他们在实现双文化方面有更大的困难。另一个是关于抢走其他已经在这里的美国人想要的工作。这也证明是不成立的。我们确实知道，许多移民会做两三份工作，
Now, some people can't really do two languages. or three. They have a real difficult time. But that doesn't mean that they don't want to. It just means that they have a harder time being able to achieve biculturalism. The other one is about taking jobs that other Americans that are already here have won it. And that also doesn't prove itself out. We know for a fact that many immigrants will take two and three jobs.
只是为了能维持生计。他们可以支付账单而不受苦。所以那种懒惰、犯罪猖獗的移民，那真的是一团糟。当人们真正查看关于此的研究和统计数据时，它已被证明是非常不正确的。移民人口中的犯罪率并不比已建立的社区高。所以我可以继续说下去。我的意思是，有一大堆这样的神话。
just so they can make it true. They can pay their bills and not suffer. So that laziness, crime-ridden immigrant, that's really a mess. And when people really take a look at the research and the statistics that are on that, it's been proven to be very incorrect. crime is not any higher in the immigrant population than in the established communities. So I could go on. I mean, there's a whole bunch of them.
一大堆神话，我们只是不断地重复它们，没有任何根据。现实情况是，我们确实有研究、知识和统计数据来证明移民是这个国家的贡献力量。您在工作中见识了很多。那么从您的角度来看，我们的移民系统需要改变什么？有很多。目前，你知道，他们试图投入更多的人来拘留移民，
A whole bunch of them is that we just keep on repeating themselves and without any foundation. And the reality is we do have the research and the knowledge and the statistics to prove that immigrants are contributing force to this country. And you've seen a whole lot in your work. So from your perspective, what needs to be? to change about our immigration system? There's quite a lot. At this point is, you know, they're trying to put in more people to detain immigrants,
但我们没有做任何事情来增加更多的法官来审理案件。这种两到三年的法庭听证等待期是荒谬的。当他们无法在法庭上获得审判时，这真的会破坏一个家庭和一个人的稳定。现在我们知道无证移民无权获得律师，但他们有权在法庭上获得审判。所以即使他们必须代表自己，我们也应该给他们机会这样做。而没有法官来做这件事，它行不通。它只是让我们的系统无法顺利运行。我们还需要培训更多的心理学家来做这种工作，为移民律师提供心理
but we're not doing anything about getting more judges to hear the cases. This languishing of two to three years to get a court hearing is absurd. It really destabilizes a family and an individual when they can't get their day in court. Now we know that undocumented immigrants are not entitled to an attorney, but they are entitled to their day in court. So even if they have to represent themselves, we should give them the opportunity to do so. And not having the judges available to do so is, it doesn't work. It just makes our system not work smoothly. We also need to train more psychologists to do this kind of work to provide the psychological
评估，以便他们能够陈述他们的案件。我们确实有研究表明，90%附有法医心理评估的案件通常都会为客户找到有利结果，所以我们确实知道它有帮助，它帮助法官，也帮助客户讲述他们为什么在这里的故事。人们不一定是因为选择而离开他们的国家，我的意思是，做出离开你所知道的一切并来到另一个国家，有时甚至不说那种语言或完全不熟悉文化，也不知道他们要面对什么的最终决定，需要付出很多。
evaluation to the immigration attorneys so that they can present their case. We do have studies that say that 90% of cases that have a forensic psychological evaluation attached to it are usually found for the for the for the for the for the client so we do know that it helps it helps the judges and it helps the client to be able to tell their story as to why they're here people don't necessarily leave their countries by choice i mean it takes a lot to make that final decision to leave what you know and come to another country where you sometimes don't even speak the language or totally unfamiliar with the culture and have no idea what they're coming to.
这是一次不可思议的磨难，一个不可思议的决定。我们需要更好的方式来理解美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）不同部门所做的可信恐惧面谈。所以当他们进行面谈时，那个人可能在心理健康方面没有太多培训，无法决定他们是否相信客户正确地讲述了他们的故事。所以那个过程需要被更好地审视。我确实知道在一些社区，心理健康临床医生被要求参与可信恐惧面谈。
It is an incredible ordeal, an incredible decision to make. We need better ways of understanding the credible fear interview that is done by the different parts of USCIS. So when they do an interview, it's an individual who may not have much training in mental health to make a decision of whether they believe a client is telling their story correctly. So that process needs to be taken, I look at it a little better. I do know that in some communities, mental health clinicians have been asked to participate in the credible fear interviews.
我没有进行过任何面谈，我也不一定主张我们这样做，但只是进行面谈的人员的培训需要更多地是创伤知情的。沿着同样的思路，您认为在哪些领域需要更多的心理学家？嗯，我当然希望看到更多的心理学家接受移民心理学的培训，这样他们就可以进行法医评估，以及当他们最终来到这里并有机会留在这个国家时，我们也可以在临床格式中解决他们正在处理的创伤、焦虑和抑郁问题。所以我们没有足够的人了解他们为了来到这里所经历的一切，以便他们可以治疗他们并能够
I have not conducted any, nor am I necessarily advocating that we do it, but it's just that the training of the individuals who do that needs to be more. trauma-informed, if you will. And along that same vein, in what areas do you think more psychologists are needed? Well, I certainly would like to see more psychologists be trained in immigration psychology so they can do the forensic evaluation as well as when they're finally here and given an opportunity to stay in this country that we can also address the issues of trauma and anxiety and depression that they are dealing with in a clinical format. So we don't have enough people who understand what they've gone through to get here so that they can treat them and be able to
帮助他们在美利坚合众国过上成功的生活。学习文化适应并真正理解你如何做到这一点，是我们学习曲线和处理移民问题的一个非常重要的过程。我们在这次谈话中谈了很多关于创伤的问题，我想转向韧性的主题。所以您参与了美国心理学会（APA）移民工作组的一份报告。您发表了一篇名为《脆弱但未破碎》（Vulnerable but not broken）的论文，那是关于来自中美洲的无人陪伴未成年人的心理社会挑战和韧性。所以在您为2019年9月刊的《监测》文章所做的采访中，您解释了发表这份报告有多重要，
help them lead a successful life in the United States. Learning acculturation and really understand how you do that is really an important process of our learning curve and addressing immigrants. We've spoken a lot during this conversation about trauma and I want to turn to the subject of resilience. So you're involved. in a report with APA's immigration working group. You published a paper called Vulnerable but but not broken and that was about the psychosocial challenges and resilience among unaccompanied minors from Central America. So in an interview you did with the Monitor article for the September 2019 issue, you explained how important it is to publish this report
因为它将造福心理健康专业人士、教师、律师、医生，以帮助确保他们适当地治疗这些弱势群体。您能详细说明一下吗？当然。所以这些通常是年轻人。我的意思是，我们谈论的是10、12、14岁的年轻人，青春期前以及青少年，他们通常从非常虐待的家庭中逃出来，无法再忍受他们在自己国家所经历的一切，并做出了来到美国的轨迹。当他们来到这里，当人们善待他们并为他们提供至少一个倾听的耳朵时，他们非常感激。
because it will benefit mental health professionals, teachers, lawyers, doctors to help ensure that they are properly treating these vulnerable populations. Can you elaborate on a bit more? Sure. So these are usually young people. I mean, we're talking about 10, 12, 14-year-old youngsters, pre-teens as well as teenagers that have escaped from usually very abusive homes that can no longer tolerate what they're experiencing in their own country and have made the trajectory to come to the United States. they are so grateful when they come and when people treat them nicely and and provide them with at least a listening ear.
所以这有助于培养一种你是值得的人的感觉，即有人关心，有人会给你时间，从而建立一个孩子面对即将到来的事情的韧性，因为他们所离开的一切通常是如此令人不安、如此丑陋，而且，好吧，他们所经历的，他们中的许多人经历了各种各样的事情。他们认为我们不会期望孩子经历过这些，看到他们的母亲被杀，看到他们的父母被带走、绑架和失踪。也许他们还有其他家庭成员性侵犯了他们。所以他们经历了一切。
So that contributes to developing a sense of that you're a person of worse, that you, that somebody cares, that somebody will give you the time of day and thereby building someone, a child's resilience to deal with what is coming next because what they've left is so usually so disturbing, so ugly and so, well, they've experienced, many of them have experienced all kinds of things. They think we would not have expected children to have experienced, seeing their mother killed, seeing their parents let away, kidnapped, and disappeared. And maybe they've had other family members who have sexually assaulted them. So they have gone through everything.
来到这个国家是一盏希望的灯塔。当他们发现有人真正关心并给予关注时，他们就能够做出回应并说，好的，我从这里有一个成长的地方。所以努力建立他们的韧性和希望是一项需要完成的不可思议的工作。我们不需要，他们很多时候被安置在寄养家庭或集体家庭中，并被拘留，就像我之前提到的，那些房子、仓库、青少年。所以这就是我们帮助他们建立韧性的地方。
And coming to this country is a beacon of hope. And when they find that they're individuals who really care and give a damn, then they're able to respond and say, okay, I have a place to grow from here. So trying to work on building their resilience and their hope is, an incredible job that needs to be done. And we don't need to be, there many times are placed in foster homes or group homes and detained in facilities, like I mentioned before, the houses, warehouses, adolescents. So that's where we help them build resilience.
因为他们不一定，这些不是犯罪的孩子，只是经历了很多的孩子。儿童和青少年有很高的韧性潜力，对吧？我的意思是，即使尽管有这些挑战，也有很高的潜力，对吗？是的，有。绝对是。是的。虽然他们经历并看到了很多，但他们仍然有能力把这些放在一边并继续前进。对于也经历过这些经历的成年人来说也是一样吗？
Because they're not necessarily, these are not criminal kids, are just kids who have gone through a lot. And there is a high potential for resilience in children and teens, right? I mean, even despite these challenges, there is a high potential, correct? Yes, there is. Absolutely. Yeah. Although they've gone through and seen a lot, they can still have the capacity to put that aside and move forward. Is that the same for adults who've also gone through these experiences?
有时。我不知道这是否一定适用于所有人。但当他们来到这里，当他们被倾听，当法庭选择听取并理解他们的故事时，就会建立起希望，他们就有恢复的潜力。但他们不一定能独自做到。所以这就是我们需要专业知识来处理的地方，来自世界各地的人。这个机构，西北移民权利项目，
Sometimes. I don't know that this is necessarily true for everybody. but when they come, when they're listened to, when the court chooses to hear them and understand their stories, and then there's hope that's built in and they have the potential to recover. But they can't necessarily do it alone. So that is where we need to have the expertise to deal with, people who come from all over the world. This agency, the Northwest Immigrant Rights,
这些人来自超过174个不同的国家。我的意思是，这不仅仅是一个中美洲问题。我们看到来自刚果、越南的人，来自我以前从未理解或听说过的文化和地方的人。对于心理学家来说，能够了解这些不同的文化以及人们互相伤害的方式和他们互相建立的方式，是一种不可思议的经历。
these people from over 174 different countries. I mean, this is not just a Central American issue. We see people from, I've seen people from Congo, from Vietnam, from places and cultures I had never understood or heard about before. And it's for the psychologist, it's an incredible experience to be able to learn about these different cultures and the way in which people can harm each other and the way in which they can build each other up.
所以这是正在发生的事情的真实证明。您能谈谈您在西北移民权利项目或难民心理健康资源网络中拥有的最好或最自豪的时刻吗？我认为是认识到这项工作很重要。所以我已经在NERP，也就是西北移民权利项目工作了超过15年，做这项工作。多年来，我一直试图引入这个话题。
So that's a true testament to what is happening. Can you talk about your best or proudest moment you've had with the Northwest Immigrant Rights Project or with the Refugee Mental Health Resource Network? I think the recognition that this work is important. So I've been at NERP, which is a Northwest Immigrant Rights Project, for over 15 years doing this work. And I have tried to introduce this topic for many years.
这确实证明了正在发生的事情。你能谈谈你在西北移民权利项目或难民心理健康资源网络中经历过的最美好或最引以为傲的时刻吗？我认为是对这项工作重要性的认可。我在西北移民权利项目（NIRP）工作已经超过15年了，一直致力于这项工作。多年来，我一直试图引入这个话题。
And nobody really was paying much attention that this was going to be a problem. I certainly didn't expect it to reach where it's at at this point. But just the recognition of the value of this work from immigration attorney, attorneys who understand now the value of the psychological evaluation has been an incredible experience. On the other side, the worst experiences are usually the ones in which we, you feel like shaking a judge and saying, but you need to understand what this individual went through before you make a ruling that sends him back to a country that will kill him, him or her. And so that's a very frustrating time to not be able to be able to help them understand. Because the first level, often when something is presented to the USCIS, and they return it and say, well, we might need more information.
当时并没有人真正注意到这会成为一个问题。我当然也没想到它会发展到今天这个地步。但是，移民律师们现在认识到了这项工作的重要性，他们理解了心理评估的价值，这是一种不可思议的经历。另一方面，最糟糕的经历通常是我们感到想摇晃法官并对他说：在你做出裁决将他送回一个会杀害他（或她）的国家之前，你需要了解这个人经历了什么。所以，当无法让他们理解时，那是一个非常令人沮丧的时刻。因为第一阶段，通常当某些东西提交给美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）时，他们会退回并说，我们需要更多信息。
Sometimes the kind of information that they're looking for is just a lack of understanding of what psychological issues are. in an individual how they present themselves, which is really frustrating because those individuals don't have any mental health background. So it's like they're just shooting in the air and asking for questions that you wonder, I can explain it to you in many different ways, but not choosing to listen is really difficult. For any psychologists we have listening, can you explain how they can get involved in helping immigrants and refugees during these challenging experiences? they have as they get into the country? There's a lot of psychological, local psychological association statewide that are beginning
有时他们寻找的信息仅仅是因为缺乏对个人心理问题的理解，以及他们如何表现自己，这真的很令人沮丧，因为这些人没有任何心理健康背景。所以这就像他们在盲目射击，问一些让你感到困惑的问题。我可以以多种不同的方式向你解释，但如果你选择不听，那就真的很困难了。对于正在收听的心理学家，你能解释一下他们如何参与帮助移民和难民度过这些充满挑战的经历吗？当他们进入这个国家时，有很多州级的心理学协会开始
to have programs to train psychologists to do this kind of work. A very good one, an example would be California. I'm aware of other ones around the country, New York, I think, has that as well. But there are different state chapters that have done a lot of work in trying to get more and more psychologists to be involved. The Physicians for Human Rights is another agency that a trained licensed mental health clinicians to do this kind of work. So it is, you have to search for it.
开展培训心理学家从事这类工作的项目。加利福尼亚州就是一个很好的例子。我知道全国其他地方也有，比如纽约，我想也有。但不同的州分会做了大量工作，试图让越来越多的心理学家参与进来。医生促进人权组织（Physicians for Human Rights）是另一个培训持照心理健康临床医生从事这类工作的机构。所以，你必须去寻找这些机会。
It's not like it's going to pop up everywhere. There aren't enough trainings that go around the country to provide for everybody who wants it, but it's available. So I've had individuals contact me and say, well, where can I get trained? And the only offering I can say, well, contact physicians for human rights and see if they are able to, if you can get into the training. The refugee network that we have is also aims at training individuals who perhaps may have put a foot into immigration, but are not quite secure in their, they're what they know, so they need a constant reassurance that we can provide through the network in our webinars and being able to train people to look for different kinds of situations that
它不会随处可见。全国范围内没有足够的培训来满足所有想要的人，但它是可用的。所以我曾有人联系我说，我可以在哪里接受培训？我唯一能说的建议是，联系医生促进人权组织，看看你是否能参加他们的培训。我们拥有的难民网络也旨在培训那些可能已经涉足移民领域，但对自己所知不够自信的人，所以他们需要通过我们的网络和网络研讨会提供持续的保证，并能够培训人们去观察各种不同的情况，
they may not have confronted. And individuals like myself are open to mentoring at all times. I take calls from anyone who's interested in doing this work and will guide you through the process. And the one thing that seems to hold psychologists back and other mental health professionals is the fact that you may be asked to testify in court. So what I say to people is if you're willing to sign your name to a report and put your license on the line, then you should be able to testify in court to what your document says. But it's still that fear of, oh, my goodness, I don't want to go to court type of thing. So that's the reluctance that many psychologists have. But we can work with that. That's something that we can teach people to do.
他们可能从未遇到过。像我这样的人随时愿意提供指导。我接受任何对这项工作感兴趣的人的电话，并将引导你完成整个过程。似乎阻碍心理学家和其他心理健康专业人员的一件事是，你可能会被要求在法庭上作证。所以我对人们说的是，如果你愿意在报告上签名并拿你的执照冒险，那么你就应该能够为你的文件内容在法庭上作证。但这仍然存在一种恐惧，哦，天哪，我不想去法庭。所以这是许多心理学家的抵触情绪。但我们可以解决这个问题。这是我们可以教人们去做的事情。
For listeners who aren't psychologists but want to help somehow, can they do anything? Do you have any advice? Yes, they can. If they live near a detention center, there are many organizations that go visit, who may have a program for a visitation program, where they go and visit an individual, maybe once a month. that's all it takes. We're not asking people to
对于那些不是心理学家但想以某种方式提供帮助的听众，他们能做些什么吗？你有什么建议吗？是的，他们可以。如果他们住在拘留中心附近，有很多组织会去探访，他们可能有探访计划，他们会去探访某个人，也许一个月一次。这就足够了。我们不是要求人们
spend many more time than that. Just visit someone who's detained, who's been there for months, who has not seen a family member and has no one to talk to. So that's usually available where detention centers are. There's other ways of helping in different communities and different churches have organizations
花费比这更多的时间。只需探访一个被拘留的人，他已经在那里待了几个月，没有见过家人，也没有人可以交谈。所以这通常在有拘留中心的地方是可行的。在不同的社区还有其他帮助方式，不同的教会有组织
within their churches where they can, where they have provided housing for immigrants that may be in transition, waiting for their interview or just struggling with trying to understand American culture and getting acculturated. So I guess there are many different ways in which we can respond to the needs of immigrants. And in each community, there are those agencies that do that. We have at the Northwest Detention Center, the AIDS Northwest is an agency that has a little trailer outside of the detention center where we can provide clothing for people who are coming out of the detention center that don't have anything.
在他们的教会内部，他们为处于过渡期、等待面试或只是在努力理解美国文化并进行文化适应的移民提供住房。所以我想我们可以通过许多不同的方式来响应移民的需求。在每个社区，都有做这些工作的机构。我们在西北拘留中心有“西北艾滋病援助组织”（AIDS Northwest），这是一个在拘留中心外有一个小拖车的机构，我们可以为那些从拘留中心出来什么都没有的人提供衣物。
They may have been picked up in Mississippi and brought to Washington in the cold or in the wintertime and so have inadequate clothing may help them get to the nearest airport so they can go back to where their family may be. connecting family members with others who got separated. So there's different agencies that do that kind of work. And that doesn't require a psychologist necessarily, just an interest. So it's amazing to think that you can just go to an attendance center and say you want to visit with someone. Are there anything people need to know about how to do that? Well, for example, and I know there's the one of the program in Chicago I'm aware of.
他们可能在密西西比州被抓获，然后被带到华盛顿，在寒冷或冬季，所以衣物不足。我们可能会帮助他们到达最近的机场，这样他们就可以回到家人的身边。将家庭成员与其他人重新联系起来。所以有不同的机构在做这类工作。这不一定需要心理学家，只需要一份热心。所以想到你可以直接去拘留中心说你想探访某人，这真是太神奇了。人们需要知道如何做到这一点吗？嗯，例如，我知道芝加哥有一个这样的项目。
And the program that we have here, we do a training. I used to be on the board of the AIDS Northwest. And so one of the things that they did was train visitors to what the kind of things to expect and what kind of things to talk about and how they can facilitate that process. So there's a tremendous need to assist these individuals when they come to this country. And that's one of the ways in which we can do that. But visiting people is really important. All is required is just spend a half an hour, 45 minutes with someone who has lost their entire.
我们这里的项目，我们进行培训。我曾经是“西北艾滋病援助组织”的董事会成员。所以他们做的一件事就是培训探访者，让他们了解会遇到什么样的事情，谈论什么样的话题，以及他们如何促进这一过程。因此，当这些人来到这个国家时，非常需要协助他们。这是我们可以做到这一点的方式之一。但探访人们真的很重要。所需要的只是花半小时、45分钟与一个失去了一切的人在一起。
They've been separated from their family. They may have lost their community and they don't know anything about the United States and have never even looked at the outside of what U.S. looks like. They may have been processed right from the border straight to Washington and they know nothing about nothing. So it's that being able to be personal to understand that we're just, human beings trying to connect with one another. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Antunia, on this topic that's incredibly important right now,
他们与家人分离了。他们可能失去了社区，对美国一无所知，甚至从未见过美国的样子。他们可能直接从边境被处理到华盛顿，对一切一无所知。所以，能够以个人身份去理解我们只是试图相互联系的人类，这一点非常重要。非常感谢您加入我们，Antunia博士，讨论这个目前极其重要、
incredibly relevant in our country, and for sharing your insights and your work. We really appreciate it. You're quite welcome. Anytime. Dr. Antunia's interview in the Monitor on Psychology, APA's magazine for members that covers science, education, psychology practice, and more is now online.
在我们国家极其相关的话题，并分享您的见解和工作。我们非常感谢。不客气。随时欢迎。Antunia博士在《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）上的采访，这是美国心理学会（APA）为会员提供的涵盖科学、教育、心理学实践等内容的杂志，现已上线。
You can find a link in our show notes and at speakingof psychology.org. Before we go, just a reminder that we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. And please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology.
您可以在我们的节目说明中找到链接，也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org。在结束之前，提醒大家我们想听到您的声音。您可以将您的评论和想法发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）是APA播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，如关于新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》（APA Journals Dialogue）和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》（Progress Notes）。
You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的Caitlin Luna。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。